hello I'm Tara Hernandez and I'm Damon
Lindelof and we are the co-creators of
peacock's new series Mrs Davis
Mrs Davis is not a person it is the name
of an all-powerful artificial
intelligence so we wanted to see what AI
would generate if we prompted it to
visualize our show
when the prompt would go a little
something like this
Mrs Davis is a series about a Nun Sister
Simone she's a great nun but she's also
cool she's an awesome Renegade nun who
rides a motorcycle with a helmet always
wear a helmet always and the nun has to
find the Holy Grail in order to destroy
this AI a quest for the Grail is going
to involve an epic adventure that's
amazing the pope of course maybe some
giant Donuts there's also a resistance
in a former hippo meat factory
hippopotamy exactly so it was part of
this underground resistance you have two
types of men you've got are like jock
strong men and the Nerds who run all the
tech who are also trying to find Mrs
Davis's server farm so they can destroy
her and it looks like our jobs are safe
for just a little while longer oh yeah
Adventure comedy heroic nun Betty Gilpin
see for yourself Mrs Davis only on
peacock